台積電啊
當然它現在每年的產值不斷的上升
如果說是缺水
缺個 10% 好了
那至少它的這個營業損失
可能高達一 、 兩千億台幣
我們常聽到算力就是國力
那我們也相信呢
AI 有一天呢
它可能可以解決任何問題
但是 AI 有一個很巨大的罩門
就是它是......
所以呢
如果說這個......
......不見的話
全球一半以上的 GDP 都會受到影響
世界經濟論壇
近幾年的全球風險報告
像今年的
已經把
AI 衍生的假訊息跟錯誤訊息
今年已經是全球風險的
兩年風險的第一名了
它甚至超過了氣候變遷
如果在未來的某一天
全球 AI 的算力突然在一夕之間崩潰
你覺得兇手會是誰呢
這個晶片戰爭突然升級了
台積電的產線被駭客攻擊了
Nvidia 的記憶體的來源斷裂了
等等的
聽起來都蠻合理的
也符合我們對於危機的想象
但如果這場 AI 的危機還不是因為駭客
也不是因為戰爭
而是因為
一場發生在森林裡的生物大滅絕呢
這聽起來八竿子打不著對吧
畢竟青蛙不見了
跟輝達的 GPU 有什麼關係呢
又或者雨林的樹倒了
跟台積電的 2 奈米又有什麼關係呢
我們常常以為啊
人類正在打造一個可以脫離自然
無限往上的數位文明
我們有核能
有空調 、 有合成藥物
我們以為自己已經住在一個
名為科技的防護罩裡了
但我們忽略了
那個防護罩的插頭
其實插在一個正在快速腐爛的基座上
而那個基座
叫做自然資本
我想請教葉欣誠教授
我們今天要討論氣候變遷
但是其實
現在人類有一種很強的科技傲慢
就算外面環境變得再糟
物種滅絕了
反正我們現在有發達的
生物科技產業
而且很多的藥物
都可以在實驗室裡面合成
分子結構呢
還可以用 AI 算出來
所以萬一哪一天
原始森林裡面的動植物
它真的滅絕了
我們人類難道會撐不下去嗎
那當然撐不下去啊
因為呢我們叫做消費者嘛
我們應該還記得我們國中生物學過
生產者消費者分解者
人類呢 很可惜
我們必須要依賴外來的物質
我們才能生活下去
不像綠色植物
它只要有水 、 二氧化碳 、 陽光
它就可以合成自己的生物碳啊
我們除了吃東西
我們很瞭解
一定是來自於自然環境之外呢
我們的藥物其實也是
根據美國（NIH：美國國家衛生局）研究
25% 現在的現代醫學藥物
就是我們所看的那些西藥
你不覺得
它好像跟自然環境有什麼關係的
也都是來自於大自然
病原體來自於大自然
藥物也來自於大自然
所以一旦如果說我們的自然環境
我們稱為自然資本
而且它提供我們生態系服務
一旦這個服務沒有的話
我們的所有的一切
包括我們的藥物來源
都可能會受到影響
那如果到了 2050 年
現在大家認為說
2050 年熱帶雨林恐怕 20%-30% 會不見
包含像阿司匹林這樣的
這種基礎藥物的來源
恐怕都會受到影響
所以呢
它這個影響恐怕不是我們一般直覺
好像化學的
跟生物無關
事實上
生物跟化學在地球上是同樣一個來源
所以現在我們連阿司匹林
都沒有辦法完全自己合成出來嗎
當然我們可以用完全化學的方法
可是化學的原料等等所有的事情
都還是來自於地球
嗯
那地球這顆星球生態系跟它的礦物
生命 、 無生命
所有的系統是連結在一起的
所以如果我們把地球的自然生態
給弄死掉的話呢
整個地球的生機基本上就消失了
也是
之前我就是去科博館訪問的時候啊
他們介紹了很多的礦物
然後我才驚覺
其實地球上
會有那麼多多彩多姿的礦物
是因為跟生物互動而形成的
還有包括除了化石燃料
還有很多很多的礦物
我們以為是無生命的
但其實它都是跟生命互動的
對對對 像琥珀啊
這都是生命啊
所以就覺得說
哎呀 這個要是
不是有生命的話
其實並不會有那麼多
多樣化的礦物
而這些礦物其實都會成為我們
不管是能源啊
或者是剛才講的藥物啊
這些東西的來源
甚至我們的休閒娛樂
所有的服務
就我們今天所享有的一切
我們這一切的服務視為理所當然
但是呢這是大自然的給予
它不是理所當然的
那我們現在聽說
我們現在經歷所謂的
第六次大滅絕
沒錯
這樣子
第六次大滅絕它的速度到底是有多快
然後它真的會
讓我們沒有辦法
這個延續我們現在的經濟產業
我們應該這麼說
每天都會有物種滅絕
但是現在根據過去的研究認為
現在地球的物種滅絕的速度
是過去穩定時期的 1,000 到 10,000 倍
所以呢依照這個速度下去的話
大概在十幾年前
事實上
生物多樣性公約就已經提醒大家
我們已經在進入第六次大滅絕的前端
過去我們經過的研究認為
有五次生物大滅絕
第五次就是恐龍滅絕
6,500 萬年前那一次
那現在呢
第六次大滅絕裡面
很重要的驅動力是人類自己
可是我們剛才討論的像是
食物 、 藥物
我可以理解
它跟自然資本還是非常有關係的
但我們臺灣最重要的護國神山
半導體產業
我們說台積電好了
那它跟森林
又或它跟生物多樣性之間
真的有什麼關係嗎
我們難道沒了這些東西
就不能有台積電嗎
我不知道大家有沒有聽過一個說法
就是台積電本身呢
是一個喝水的怪獸
因為半導體的製程
不但是耗電
也非常的耗水
那水資源
我以前是讀水資源的
水資源不是天上下雨
我們就有水資源啊
要能夠用到的水才是水資源
所以呢自然環境能夠如何涵養水源
是我們能夠取得水資源的
一個重要的前提
一旦森林不見了
草原不見了
自然環境破壞了
天上下的雨
最後就變成泥沙
變成土石流
它不會變成我們可以用的水資源
所以呢
如果說我們不保護我們的環境
不保護生態
讓森林消失的話
有一天台積電它有再高級的製程
無水可用
也沒有辦法生產
所以教授你的意思是說
我們在晶圓廠
它真正的上游
其實就是自然資源
當然現在大家都覺得
稀土好像是自然資源
那些是比較稀缺的資源
可是我們覺得那些多的
就覺得它不是資源了嗎
如果沒有水的話
一切的生產活動是無法進行的
那具體來說
這規模有多大
台積電啊
當然它現在每年的產值不斷的上升
那現在看來的是 2.38 兆台幣
如果說是缺水
缺個 10% 好了
或 15%
而且如果是等比例
可能會更嚴重
那至少它的這個營業損失
可能高達一 、 兩千億台幣
那這個恐怕對我們來講
是不可承受之重
剛才講的這些事情
其實打破了很多人的直覺
因為我們過去談氣候變遷
很容易變成一種道德勒索
就是大家要愛地球 、 愛環保
那如果你不環保呢
就是不愛地球
不顧北極熊的死活
這樣子但是聽老師剛才這樣講
其實保護自然
是一種非常現實的成本效益分析
那整個自然呢
就像是我們的母公司一樣
而我們人類的經濟呢
是它的子公司
那母公司呢
它源源不絕的提供原料
或提供資源
甚至幫忙擦屁股
但如果母公司都破產了
那子公司呢
很有可能是無法正常去營運的
所以想請教教授
如果說我們把這些數字給量化了
那全球經濟
對於我們大自然這個母公司的
的依賴程度到底有多高
我想應該簡單來說
一半甚至一半以上
全世界的 GDP
如果把全球的 GDP 加起來的話
大概就有一半呢
依賴是很健康的生態系
所以呢
如果說這個自然資本不見的話
全球一半以上的 GDP 都會受到影響
我們一般講的這個服務包括什麼
像我們講的授粉
有蜜蜂授粉
如果沒有授粉的話
不會開花
植物不會開花
不會結果
我們就不用沒有東西可以吃了
還有森林木材的供應
臺灣我們沒什麼感覺
那如果說各位到像美國或歐洲
他們有很多房子都是木造的
恐怕連房子都蓋不起來
那另外呢
譬如說魚
我們每天吃的魚
在海裡面的魚
或者說這個河川裡面的魚類
水生動物
這些都是非常重要的資源
那這些資源全世界
應該講 44% 以上
它都會大量依賴生物多樣性
大量依賴自然環境
而在亞洲
這個比例更高
一個研究跟我們講說
亞太地區有 63% 的這個GDP
大概都跟生物直接相關
那另外呢
我覺得
剛才您有提到氣候變遷
我們講到氣候變跟生物多樣性
有什麼關係
現在事實上呢
現在全球的氣候變遷
和生物多樣性論述
在過去這幾年有個重大的改變
就是聯合國的這兩個公約的智庫合作
現在建構了一個新的
新三角關係
人 、 氣候跟自然環境
就說人氣候變遷生物多樣性
三者之間的任兩者連在一起的關係
構成了我們現在大概
必須要去注意的這些複雜概念的
大概 70%-80% 以上
所以這三個 agent
三個 agent
三個主題
三個主題 好
生物多樣性跟人類的行為
然後或是生物多樣性跟氣候
或者說氣候跟人類
各自有各自的
都有雙向的關係
所以你看
這個加起來的話就有 6 個箭頭
嗯
不一樣的方向
而且是互相影響的
所以從老師的角度會怎麼樣去
讓我們理解這個所謂的三角關係
譬如說我們剛剛講的這些
可能這個因為天氣下了暴雨
然後可能暴雨就會讓這個土壤沖蝕
更容易發生對森林造成破壞
可是如果都不下雨
森林也就枯死了
它其實就會有個關係
那同樣的呢
我們現在的氣候能夠穩定的
維持在現在這個狀態
是因為我們大氣中的二氧化碳
濃度不會太高
那大家都瞭解
很重要的碳匯
就是把二氧化碳吸收到地面的
重要的光合作用就是來自於森林
所以都是相互關係的
而我們人類就是依賴這個穩定的氣候
還有所有的生物資源活下來的
人類的活動
排放二氧化碳
破壞森林
破壞自然環境
也就都會對氣候
對生物多樣性造成損害
所以呢大致上這樣可以看得出來
的確是相互都有關係
就好像三足鼎立
如果你把其中的一足給它破壞掉
就全垮了
就垮了這樣子
那而且這個會稍微損害一點點
它可以搖搖擺擺這樣子
但是一邊損害更多
那就很糟糕了
因為它是一個不太穩定的結構
如果一根腳抽掉以後
可能就整個系統就崩潰了
嗯
那這個就讓我更好奇了
既然這件事情
它跟錢跟經濟那麼有關係
但其實我們很多時候
我們看到大家在討論氣候變遷啊
討論全球暖化啊
這些主流的輿論裡面呢
大家還是在討論說
北極熊被熱死了啊
北極熊瘦到瘦成皮包骨了
或者說人類自己要熱死了啊
最近很很多是這樣講
那我們是不是應該從教育端這邊
就開始
做一些改變呢
去把我們的論述調整成
不要都只是對於遙遠
單一物種的這種關懷
而是去改成
對於自身更迫切的
經濟危機的一種警戒
當然我覺得非常重要
在教育或傳播上面
我們有一個名詞叫做心理距離
嗯就是
你覺得這件事情
到底跟你的關係有多遠
北極熊
北極熊是一個很奇特的一個概念
對於小朋友而言
我到中小學去演講
越年輕的小朋友
他們聽到北極熊越有感覺
可是北極熊是不會出現在臺灣的
除了在動物園之外啊
所以呢對我們來講
那是一個遙遠的物種
那對我們而言
如果我們把我們對於氣候變化的關懷
或者行動
連結在一個遙遠的物種
在臺灣不出現的物種上
其實心裡距離是遙遠的
而且呢現在我剛剛特別有提到
聯合國最近的論述
很多都改變了
大概從 2010 年開始
聯合國已經把永續發展教育
結合氣候變教育
做成了當時的目標
也就是說呢
我們不再會是從管末處理的角度
來看待氣候變遷
我們保護北極熊
北極熊為什麼要我們保護
因為氣候變遷
已經造成了對它的影響了
我們要拯救北極熊
這個是後果性的論述哦
我們現在源頭處理的話
就是我們要減碳
我們不要讓氣候變遷越來越嚴重
那所以呢
包括我們的教育的概念
過去我們用環境教育的角度
來看待氣候變教育
但是現在呢
我們前幾年的修法
我們在溫室氣體
減量與管理法
過渡到現在的氣候變遷因應法
已經把氣候變遷教育
重新定位為
以永續發展為導向的氣候變遷教育
所以呢就像國威剛剛提到的
我們去談氣候變遷
不是拯救一個單一物種
不管它是北極熊或臺灣黑熊
而是我們要去考慮的
是整個人類的經濟社會
跟環境的整體
所以這跟我們的生活
跟我們家庭的收入
跟我們自己外的就業
其實都是非常非常有關的
嗯
我覺得其實現在還有一個隱然的概念
應該說是錯誤的概念
就是大家聽到永續這個詞的時候
有時候其實沒有真正理解它的意義
大概就想到環保
哎對對對
就只想到環保
但其實永續更重要的是
我們這個文明要繼續繁榮昌盛
它必須要有一個基礎在上面
當然當然
而不是
這跟很多人想著說永續
就是限制我現在衝一波
給我很多的限制
讓我現在不能
勇敢的去做所有可以賺錢的事情
我覺得
這反而是一種很奇怪的一種理解
事實上
這個現象在全世界各地都存在
真的但在臺灣特別嚴重
真的
我以前在政府服務的時候呢
我也還記得
當時的這個行政院
國家永續發展委員會的秘書處
是設在環保署
當時我就提出過這樣的一個問題
我說它為什麼設在環保署
那這樣會不會其他的部會
都覺得永續跟它沒什麼關係
甚至變成一種限制
變成一種我要去抵抗的東西
有點這種概念
很怪
但是我要說
從 1987 年聯合國發佈的那個
我們共同的未來報告書
裡面其實就明確定義了
永續發展就是經濟 、 社會 、 環境
三位一體
這個兼籌並顧的均衡發展
那我們呢
當然會用自己比較熟悉的角度
去看待這個問題
因為很多國家在一開始的時候
都是環保問題特別嚴重
才關心到這件事情
而不是因為很窮
但是有很多的國家是因為太貧窮了
所以才開始關切永續的問題
而聯合國的永續發展
從以前到現在
我認為到未來都一樣
第一要務是消除貧窮
所以大家可以注意一下
SDG 的第一個就是消除貧窮
而且其實我們看到很多情況
就是因為
可能太貧窮了
以至於
就鋌而走險
很容易反而去破壞了自己原本的生存環境
當然
因為聯合國那麼多年來都有一句口號
就是貧窮是永續發展的最大敵人
嗯
就得要把這個概念
讓大家更瞭解這件事
我們日子要先過得下去
我們才能夠
談我們要怎麼保護環境
要不然你就會去森林裡面
把黑猩猩綁架來
拿去變成肉拿來吃
如果連下一頓飯在哪裡都不知道
就跟他談環保
這是一件不太務實的事情啊
那我覺得我們臺灣
當然大部分的情況
我們已經走過這個階段了
就像老師剛才講的
我們將這個溫室氣體減量與管理法
本來好像就是一個
環境出發的一個草案
已經改成了氣候變遷因應法
那老師覺得
現在這樣的氣候變遷因應法
它已經能夠涵蓋我們
想要達到的目標
氣候變遷因應法
我覺得相對是完整的
因為以前我們談溫室氣體減量
只有在減緩嘛
那現在其實調適很重要
因為越來越多科學家認為
我們要達到這個淨零排放啊
難度非常高
也就是說世紀末的升溫
目前看來保守估計應該是攝氏 2.5-3℃
如果說是這樣的一個上升的幅度的話
大家就要準備衝擊
那準備衝擊的話
調適就變得很重要
所以這個比較完整架構之下呢
我覺得現在的氣候變遷教育
它所看待的是不但是保護環境
從經濟面做源頭減量
還有我們要如何確保自己在未來
可以活得安全
可以讓人類這個物種可以永續發展
我覺得這個才是現在的氣候變遷教育
該著力的方向
嗯
之前我看過一種說法
就是科學家努力的
把所有的自然資源
自然資本
都換算成我們可以理解的金錢
金錢價值
老師覺得這樣子的做法
是有效的嗎
有
因為人啊
很務實
用什麼方式最好溝通
這個值多少錢
那我們可以換一個方向來講
如果你沒有這個的話
你覺得你損失多少錢
所以就會
用願付值的角度
或是機會成本的角度來抵換
最後就知道說
假設我們今天臺灣
假設臺灣的森林少了一半
你覺得你會損失多少
那你就問他說
你願意花多少錢去維護這一半的森林
加起來之後就是整個社會的願付價值
事實上這些價值是非常高的
但這會不會就是陷入所謂的公地悲劇
也就是說很多人覺得說
可是那一塊森林我又用不到
或是說其實我的生活我好像跟它無關
這個就是在環境經濟學裡面
有兩種價值
一個叫使用價值
一個叫做非使用價值
非使用價值是不是直接使用
但是它一定連得上
所以就像我們覺得
我們該保護日月潭的水質
那台北地區的水又不是日月潭來的
可是那個地方的水保護它的象徵意義
對我來講
我覺得我也會比較安全
所以呢這還是可以有
之間可以有相關性的
那倒不是直接使用
因為整體環境的品質
是讓我們的整體的生活品質
提升的前提
這會不會很仰賴
比較能夠
站在系統面或站在比較高位的人
必須看懂這件事情
但是反過來說
假設我沒有在那麼高位
或者說我沒有那麼好的系統思考的人
很多跟我一樣的人
會不會其實就很難理解
我覺得這就
是我們的教育
我們的教育裡面應該要非常強調
因為永續發展教育
有個非常重要的兩大元素
一個是系統思考
一個是批判思考
那國威剛提到
我們其實從一開始到現在
都在談的是系統思考嘛
系統裡面各個元素之間的關係
那另外呢
批判思考是
我們要能夠批判自己原來的既成概念
過去我們可能認為不就是 A 到 B 嗎
現在跟你講說 B 也會到 A 哦
而且還有個 C 跟 A 跟 B 連在一起
整個系統連在一起之後
我們自我批判
自己不斷的挑戰自己原來的成見
對於整個事情的瞭解才是全面
因為這樣才看得到真正的解決方案
我覺得很有趣的是我們
即使我沒有在台積電工作
或者說我沒有擁有台積電的股票
但是假設今天老師剛才那樣講
去問說
假設台積電不在了
你願意花多少錢把它保留下來
就是我們假設台積電是個自然資源
我就會覺得說
那很重要哎
對臺灣很重要哎
雖然說那當然
因為臺灣的根本嘛
因為它是總體經濟的話
這個每一個人在裡面都會受到影響
對
但是很多人沒有辦法同樣的去理解
假設一座森林或一個山頭不見了
你願意花多少錢把它保護起來
我覺得國威剛剛講的很好
那個就是我們的母公司啊
所以會不會是其實我們需要有一個
像每天股票在播報那個數字一樣
每天在那邊告訴大家
我們今天
玉山這座森林
它的股值又上漲了
我覺得有一天搞不好真的會啊
因為現在全世界在發展一個 credit
就是像我們的信用卡
那個信用叫生物多樣性信用
嗯
就是說以後大家就會用這個金融
或金錢價值的角度
來溝通我們到底生物資本還剩多少
嗯
真正的真護國神山呢
其實大家很不瞭解它的價值
當然
台積電這種護國神山呢
大家覺得說它的價值
很顯著
然後很在乎
即使你不一定跟它有關
那我覺得這個真的是蠻有趣的一件事
就是我們用這個譬喻的方式
譬喻久了以後呢
大致想到護國神山就是一個工廠
其實那個山跟山上的森林
才是真正的護國神山
但接下來有一個很大的矛盾
就是
包括台積電在內
我們臺灣很多的產業呢
其實現在都在這個 AI 浪潮裡面
事實上全世界都在瘋 AI
大學裡面也是
那我們常聽到算力就是國力
那我們也相信呢
AI 有一天呢
它可能可以解決任何問題
不管它叫 AGI 或是 ASI
Artificial super intelligence
那氣候變遷問題呢
那當然也包含在裡面嘛
對不對
某些人的想法
但是 AI 有一個很巨大的罩門
就是它是吃電怪獸
它也是用水怪獸
那未來的這個 AI 模型呢
可能
需要整座核電廠來供給一座算力中心
又或者是好幾座的
綠能電廠來養它
這有點像是
在玩疊疊樂
我們又想要蓋高
讓文明可以持續進化
但同時呢
我們又在抽它的地基
也就是我們剛才說的這個自然資本
我們這個母公司
但是
以人類的貪心程度
或想要前進的程度來說的話
這個 AI 發展是不可能停止的
好 所以我想要請教教授
到底是 AI 會先用光我們僅存的資源
還是 AI 能夠先找到解救
我們整個世界的方法
這個我想
國威這個問題
我可覺得
不同的人一定會給不同的答案啊
那 AI 業者
他也會給你講個樂觀的答案
不過我想我們客觀一點
我認為目前的角度來看呢
AI 是一個吃電怪獸
而目前全世界的用電
事實上綠電的成分並不高
譬如說臺灣
現在我們大概 85%-90% 的火力發電
所以我每度電背後
代表了將近 500 公克的二氧化碳排放量
在全世界而言是非常高的哦
在這樣的情況之下
如果說
NVIDIA 來臺灣設了一個算力中心的話
那個耗電是一定增加的
以全世界角度來看
現在統計資料都顯示
未來 10 年 、 20 年之內
這個 AI 的算力衍生的電力消耗
會變好幾倍
那這樣的情況之下呢
我們就知道它是吃電怪獸
喝水怪獸
所以我們剛剛前面已經講過
它就會對
我們的自然環境造成影響
還有發電這件事情啊
發電這件事情
不是把東西拿去燒了就會發電了
我們還是有很多電力的根本
是來自於自然資源
那設置
所有的這個發電
然後所有的這個電力系統
也都是立足在我們的
真正的土壤之上的
一旦我們的自然環境受到損害
我們恐怕連支撐 AI 的力量都沒有了
所以呢
就好像是
我們一直在在意自己的大腦
結果最後身體壞掉了
最後還是沒有辦法好好的活下去
我覺得這個概念呢
我們必須要注意
就是只有強健的身體
才是一切的根本嘛
我們從小都這麼學的嘛
那對我們來講
強健的身體就是地球的生態
但是我們聽過很多的 AI 樂觀主義者
他們會認為像
NVIDIA 推出的
這個孿生地球啊
Earth-2 這樣子的科技
又或者 Google Deepmind 它們推出的
蛋白質折疊的
AI 預測的軟體這樣子的系統呢
其實可以幫我們解決
不管是我們的疾病問題
又或者是我們的
環境問題
那難道說
我們真的沒有辦法
在這個前進的過程中
取得一個平衡嗎
我覺得啊
這個就是互動關係嘛
剛我們講雙向
AI 當然也會幫助我們解決
很多氣候變遷衍生的問題
那這個 AI 也可以幫助我們解決
因為生物多樣性
而造成的
比方醫藥或食物匱乏的問題
所以呢這是一場賽跑
等於說毀滅或是成長
誰先發生
那我覺得現在比較好的方式
就是我們要瞭解互動的關係
那我們採取比較穩健的做法
我覺得是比較好的
那當然我們也必須要承認
人類是不會放棄 AI 的
AI 一定會越來越厲害的
所以我們還是要善用 AI 的算力
跟 AI 帶給我們的方便
解決這些問題
但是同時間
我們也不能把 AI 看成一個
只是好的東西而已
它是兩面刃
所以就隨時瞭解 AI 可能的副作用
甚至反作用
但是善用 AI 的正面效益
嗯
我蠻有感觸的
因為我看到很多的
包括這些科技巨頭啊
他們常常
可能是為了宣傳
也可能是為了真的想要做這些事情
就很努力的在推 AI for science
好就是 AI 可以幫助科學家
來加速他們的研究
來為社會做出貢獻
但是
就在這樣子的
一個比較正面價值的掩蓋之下呢
我們看到的是很多
AI 被拿來濫用
比如說
拿來駭入其它系統啊
又或者說拿來詐騙啊
或者拿來做各式各樣啊
這個負面的行為
而就在這樣子
好像我們覺得
它既然有好處
那我們也不要掩蓋它的壞處
可是就在這樣子
好像不知道要如何取捨
或者說
又把它當成一個很中立的工具
的情況之下
其實
我們走在一條很危險的鋼索上面
因為人類現在邁入下一個發展階段
這個發展階段到底會墮向深淵
還是會
突然就找到了未來的出路
我覺得現在大家是沒有什麼把握的了
那我覺得呃
我們可以看個世界經濟論壇
近幾年的全球風險報告
像今年的
已經把
AI 衍生的假訊息跟錯誤訊息
今年已經是全球風險的
兩年風險的第一名了
它甚至超過了氣候變遷
後來居上
對
AI 衍生的那個叫
disinformation and misinformation
mis- 是錯的
dis- 是虛假的
刻意製造的假訊息
像我們現在看了很多的這些影片
我知道那是假的
在開一些政治人物的玩笑
以後恐怕我沒有辦法發現它是假的了
那就糟糕了
那就可能會引起引發一些誤會
甚至國家和國家之間的戰爭
都有可能啊
所以呢
其實 AI 它的兩面刃的特性
我覺得在教育裡面我們也應該要強調
嗯
所以這就是我接下來要請教教授的
我們現在當然知道
科技進展的很快
所以包括臺灣在內
很多人都想要從事科技領域
所以去選科系啊
還是選相關的科系
這樣子
但是如果照我們剛才討論的脈絡
自然作為
這些科技業的母公司
那難道我們不會覺得說
唸生命的
或是唸生態的
這些專業的人呢
這些學生
他們的重要性被貶低了嗎
又或者說
其實我們更需要這些領域的專業
來融入到我們整個的經濟脈動
經濟發展裡面
的確這樣
而且已經發生了
因為過去這幾年
生物多樣性啊
在 2022 年的 11 月
當時聯合國的生物多樣性公約通過了
昆明蒙特婁的全球框架
裡面呢
就把企業的責任放在裡頭了
就說企業要負責
你有一個義務
要負責全世界的生物多樣性的復育
在這樣的情況下
過去這幾年
其實大量的生態 、 生科
森林相關的科系畢業的同學
不管是碩班博班或是大學部的
畢業之後呢
就被金融機構
或是各種科技公司網羅進去
為什麼
因為這些公司
它必須要去因應生物端性的挑戰
氣候變遷也是一樣
大氣系畢業的同學
現在也是到企業界去工作
那這樣的趨勢
我相信就是剛我們提到的永續的概念
它不只是環境保護
它已經跟產業的發展
完全結合在一起了
我們與其說他是未來的趨勢
應該說他是已經發生的事實
嗯
已經不能再講什麼
念生科一生科科
時代已經不一樣了
而且就是過去這幾年發生的
而且未來我相信呢
這種我們所謂的斜槓跨域
以後會變常態了
也因為 AI 的關係
也的確有比較多的能力
來做這個跨域的
對
不過我還要強調
我覺得跨域歸跨域
我覺得基本的知識
跟基本的學習真的還是非常重要
我在學校教書教了快 30 年了
我覺得基本功
也是用 AI 的根本
不然你連問 AI 什麼問題
可能都搞不清楚啊
對 要能夠提供很好的脈絡
你的能力越強
AI 能夠賦能你成長的那個幅度就越高
就是讓強者更強
真的
要獲得這樣的基本功
老師覺得現在的學生應該要怎麼做
我覺得呢
我們在學習的時候呢
有時候可能先忘掉自己啊
是自然組或社會組這件事情
我就是一個全方位的學習
但是我對我自己的專業
或是我們講那個叫 Domain knowledge
就是自己的核心本業
一定要至少做到 80 、 90 分
那其他的一些相關的領域
我可以 60 分 、 70 分
只要跟其它的領域的人溝通就好了
訓練自己成為一個全才
過去我們講跨領域人才
我甚至覺得無領域人才
恐怕才是未來需要的
可是呢
還是要回到我們這個地球母公司
如果地球母公司倒閉了
大家都不用再做下去了
嗯
今天很高興邀請到老師來跟我們聊一聊
自然資本好
這個很抽象的概念
它如何實際的在影響我們
特別是臺灣的社會以及臺灣的經濟
我想很多人可能都忘記這件事情
當我們現在越來越需要
從大自然去獲取解決方案的時候呢
我們同時間也在加速破壞它
自我修復以及創造的能力
我覺得這真的是一個很吊詭
也很必須要警惕的事情
當然
所以呢
我們這幾年
幫教育部在推這個氣候變遷教育
那我想我們搭配著
現在我們氣候變應法的這個修法
我想未來的角度應該是更全面
生物多樣性
過去覺得好像是生物多樣性教育
才會觸及的領域
氣候變遷
因為它是一切的根本
所以呢生物多樣性跟氣候變遷
跟人完全結合在一起之後
這也是未來
我們在教育部
或環境部的這個體系下面
我們全面推
這個氣候變遷教育的非常重要的切入點
嗯
那我在這邊也想問問大家
想象一下你是 10 年後的自己
那個時候呢
手上的藥物選擇變少了
所居住的城市呢
面臨嚴重的限水
甚至是淹水
而且你吃的食物價格呢
也因為氣候變遷
帶來的極端天氣的事件而飆漲
在那個時候呢
如果有一個選擇擺在你面前
就是去犧牲個人
可能一點點的短期便利
而去支持
一個能夠長期保護集水區森林
保護海岸生態的政策
在那個當下你會優先考量什麼呢
你會做出什麼樣的選擇呢
那在下一次做出任何的消費
以及投資決策的時候
你有沒有辦法把生物多樣性的風險
好像看不見的成本
納入你去計算合理價格的公式裡面呢
再次感謝老師今天的分享
那關於氣候變遷
對於經濟以及政治更深入的探討呢
我們將在思想實驗室裡面呢
再跟大家深入的來聊
記得訂閱泛科學
開啓小鈴鐺
我們下次再見